ça normal qu'ils soient autorisés à
participer parce que je rappelle en 2018
il ya quand même une coupe du monde en
russie alors que la russie avait déjà
envahi la crimée je rappelle aussi que
la prochaine coupe du monde c'est au
qatar où on peut aussi se poser quelques
questions sur les droits de l'homme donc
moi je trouve ça un petit peu hypocrite
finalement si on n'autorise pas les
joueurs russes à participer à la
compétition elle est virée au lard est à
peine d'être toujours comme ça non mais
c'est vrai je sais bien qu'elle ait un
très bon y arriver dès ce notamment mais
alors élevé des caisses qui les y former
mais je dois le dire et les libéraux 2
mondial oui il fallait payer cheveux
blancs tu vas le dirai oui mais rien
pour lui c'est pas responsable et pas du
tout responsable mais si les politiques
à signer une décharge à des enjeux
condamné et n'ont dès lors pas demandé
mais moi c'est très bien que s'ils
disent les contrastes et si derrière
c'est très dangereux pour eux-mêmes 5
wimbledon ne l'a pas fait les a exclues
mais double cd abrutis annoncé le grand
tournoi du monde avec tolérance pas du
tout quand on m'a dit on étudiera
n'importe quand quand on bloque c'est
plus grand n'importe quoi il ya quatre
tournois doublure autour du monde et
wimbledon en fait partie mais ce n'est
pas le plus grand combat dion non mais
les loups et les raisons c'est le plus
mythique non pas du tout on attend les
chiffres non celui qui songe aussi au
moins est au dessus mais ce panneau
monde des super noms là le problème de
jc que tu dis aucune l'arrêté wimbledon
a par ailleurs dit pas de bêtise ya que
des mecs qui jouent sur terre baky qui
jouant service volée qui gagne cependant
d un mandat au moment pas de bêtises
connaissez rien au tennis rien mais rien
d'autre sur de journalisme arrière n'y a
rien à general
finalement commenté voilà géraldine elle
connaît tennis ou pas non non pas comme
un goût amer de gâchis d'accord avec
chip ou sur quoi c'est vrai bah oui
évidemment oui encore une fois il n'a
aucune nuance il a encore une cinquante
pour cent des russes sont contre cette
guerre bien sûr vise à guider qui le
disent mais on prend des risques et
arrêteront leur famille qu'ils soient là
bas soit agressé par petit nourrisson
akin je dois tu proposes tu ne joues pas
alors que tu es contre la guerre
d'acteur où tu joues et tu mettes avait
mis en danger c'est ça tu es proposition
nuancé gilles joue pas comme d'habitude
y aucune n'est en danger par doc alors
on peut dire ah ben oui oui tiens moi je
trouve que justement il me donne a été
très courageux roland-garros est très
lâche pas du tout vous expliquer
pourquoi moi je dis bravo en longueur
nord fait bravo et bravo mais à idron
longueurs d'aston martin est à demi
pardonnée et je le dis
je le dis à tous mais ça vibre au garrot
si je vois que gerra d'une manière
vitale à roland garos vous allez voir
ces bêtes donné que dans les dents les
voilà dans le village de roland garros
avait bien répondu
vous pouvez l'invité merci à l'évasion
d'abord gdf rub lèvent tous ces joueurs
là ils ont jamais vécu en russie ils
sont tous partis s'entraîner soit à
cannes soit barcelone soit marées alors
et alors mais bon tu vas me dire que
j'ai alors je donne ma mère important
mais ça évidemment il colis qu'autre
chose puisque messi parce que si on
partait d'un riche ni cédées aux
oligarques russes qui sont partis très
tôt voilà on marque russe
andreï medvedev il pèse pas 100 millions
d'euros d'impôts de bêtises excusez moi
en tout cas je trouve que c'est juste
pas bien il aurait dû dire quoi on est
contre la guerre il devrait se prononcer
comme il doit se prononcer non big l'utp
pas belle mais pas témoin ou mais
wimbledon ils ont fait une énorme erreur
et brownies et regardez bien les gens là
ne les aviez pas et devient symbole a
par exemple qui est ukrainien il vient
d'y allumer l'ordinateur regard des
bouts de chasse qui se passe et e
medvedev rible avec ça ils doivent
parler doivent ils doivent se prononcer
contre cette guerre d'autant plus qu'ils
vivent pas du tout je suive pas d'une
france où il doit plaider leurs phares
ils doivent pas être pénalisés dit pas
de bêtise d'adolescent
qui veulent le comédien rigide qui
travaillent plus non plus les artistes
ce qui donne du bonheur en fait plus
aucun retrait n'est il pas mais dans
quel sens de l'épuré de la fraude
asnières pays on va pas on peut pas
parce que je suis le montre la guerre
on peut laisser parler les autres
j'aimerais avoir raymond laquelle il se
réveille doucement mon message
[Rires]
au sport le sport c'est autre chose
comme a dit benjamin sexe comme un
acteur ça donne du rêve c'est pas parce
qu'ils vont pas là roland garros que
poutine mais des rabbins j'arrête la
guerre à toi
ou moi je partais la ligne du but oui on
avait fait la coupe du monde en 2018 ya
le qatar aussi qui va arriver comment
qui je suis président
je suis parti que tu peux pas de
problème sa famille en russie bien sûr
mais refuse à mes amis en russie dont
l'un d'eux ils ont tous partie de ses
organisateurs ils ont rien d'inattendu
ce qui compte c'est moi voilà
j'espère que vous serez pas habiter à
roland garros je suis déjà invités bah
je vais leur dire de vous des invités on
verra les jeunes à moubarak paraît que
j'ai le pouvoir mais j'espère je vais
vous désinvité de roland garros pourtant
vous avez dit que vous avez que les
organisateurs étaient des [ __ ]
à la jeunesse appelée
je les connais bien et je pense que je
les connais mieux mais ça c'est sûr vous
connaissez tous le monde devant moi oui
je pense que oui donc je vais dormir
ce pouvoir de nuisance un oui
roland garros ne s'immiscera pas là
qui pensent qu'elle sera plus jamais à
boulogne
[Rires]
mais ça peut être une grosse arc après
je pense que je vais le faire quand même
une petite dalle non madame non madame
c'est par ce biais non madame agnès à
elle ou moi ça donne c'est génial c est
moi je vais le dire
je vous le jure
c'est elle ou sur les joueurs qui
n'étaient pas invités par qui
d'abord j'ai la chance d'avoir stan
wawrinka
et vous savez comment si je savais qu'il
soit d'y aller vous avez quand tu joues
étaient invités à vous achèterez
mobilier je
vérifierai que vous avez bien acheté mon
sens et vous verrez donc annoncé mais je
peux vous des licenciés
en fait que vous rayer de la carte
pour qui on veut un dialogue non non
code qui maintenant ont le droit de dire
ce qu'on veut mais quoi
spock tennis non une petite info qui est
passé comme ça inaperçu vous avez dit
vous faites partie du stuff wii relax et
son ami
de
la tête parce que mental quoique à qui
le parti de son staff pas du tout c'est
un ami ouais ouais je bouge bien on est
en train de préparer roland garros c'est
vrai et allait être au niveau des jambes
bien sûr qu'il va être au niveau vous
allez voir et c'est un saint génis va
vous le préparateur physique vous êtes
quoi exactement mentale touche près
partout je vous dire c'est un gourou
quand vous avez une personne comme moi à
côté de vous ouais vous êtes sûr et
certain 1 vous serez pas éliminé lors
des trois premiers tours
parce que dans la tête par fanny on a
regardé les résultats de près alors
ouais mais julien et jeunes docteurs et
je ne pense pas qu'un holla holla cédé 1
go j'adore j'ai déjà des trucs d'iao dit
géraldine qu'on ne l'invitera pas
[Applaudissements]
militant bah c'est quelqu'un de sidi que
vous en voudra pas vous serez pas miner
la fédé non je voudrais écoute non non
c'était ma croûte et mâcon si cette
personne dit que très peu vite et vous
ce
match pour vous avoir des passions
qui monte allez-y n'hésitez pas faites
pas je vous prendrai pas roland garros